(rires)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des déguisements,
dede la barbe à papa, un antidoe
contre la peur. Des moments
d'insouciance bienvenus pour
ces enfants, victimes innocentes
d'une ererre insensée.
"C'est très important de
leur apporter des sourires de
la j d d dit Maxime Nichtailo,
pour leur montrer qu'on peut
revivre et être heureux après
l'horreur."
Et au chapitre de l'horreur,
la région de Borodyanka n'a
pas été épargnée. C'est une
des villes martyres de la
guerre, théâtre de bombardements
massifs et d'exécutions
sommaires. Aucun immeuble ici
n'est intact et l'école ne fait
pas exception. Lolololdats
russes en ont fait leur quartier
général et l'ont laissé enèèèète
sont retirés.
Nazarro Panasenko y remet
les pieds pour la première fois.
Cet élève de cinquième année
est resté terré dans la cave
chez lui avec sa mère et
sa grarererere jusqu'au départ
des soldats russes.
Le garçon de 10 ans a
l'impression aujourd'hui d'en
avoir au moins deux de plus,
hanté par des images et des sons
nenenene le quittent plus.
Lmemememement des avions qui
volent au-dessus de sa tête
et le sifflement des bombes.
Il en a conservé un clignement
des yeux incontrôlable,e e e e .
"J'ai encore peur quand
j'entends des explosions,
dit-il, je me mets à trembler."
Ivanka et Nastia ne cachent
pas leur impatience de retourner
à l'école, même si ce n'est
que pour une brève visite.cacace
sur un chapitre sombre
de leur jeune existence.
Même si les combats se sont
éloignés, elles vivent encore
dans la peur de voir des soldats
russes revenir et leurs tanks
tirer sur les maisons. Leurs
mère se sentent désemparées.
"Les fillettes sont encore
effrayées, disent-elles.
Elles se mettent à pleurer ou
courent se réfugier à la cave
dès qu'elles entendent
des explosions."
Les enfants qui ont vécu de
près les horreurs de la guerre
ici vont clairement rester
marqués pour la vie. Et peu
importe la distance qui la
sépare de la ligne de front,tots
qui en gardera des séquelles.
"Pourquoi les enfants ont-ils
peur? Parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'imagination, dit cette
psychologue, et ils imaginent
toujours le pire, comme
la guerre nucléaire."
"Et pour un enfant,
ajoute-t-elle, il est aussièèèèr
que ses parents ne sont pas
en mesure de le protéger."
Il est donc important que
les enfants retrouvent le plus
rapidement possible une vie
normale. Mais leur retour encla.
Beaucoup d'écoles sont utilisées
pour héberger des familles
déplacées. Celles qui n'ont
pas été au moins partiellement
détruites, comme celle-ci,
à Makariv.
Sa directrice est submergée
par la peine chaque fois
qu'elle y met les pieds.
Elle n'arrive pas à s'expliquer
que l'on puisse ainsi s'en
prendre aux infrastructures
rtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtout,
aux enfants.
Ici Jean-François Bélanger, R v